yeah what what did work last year is is
tougher this year so naturally you need
to work smarter or harder more
structured you need to have a better way
of how you position yourself you need to
be Innovative if you're not just talking
recruitment all the time and you're
talking about your products and how you
off on outcome driven services and
that's what the difference is for this
year is that the recruiters that do
great are the people that don't act like
recruiters instead of people that build
relationships offer Solutions
etc etc and you know the last few months
or a couple months for us we've have
some phenomenal months because people
are just turning the whole service to a
Next Level Nas what you didn't need to
do last year because people could just
ping a CV out and you know get a win out
of it yeah you just can't do that this
year